all right well it's a better topic than
double
what's that was a better topic than just
talking about local government talking
about being I agree okay so we are live
um welcome guys to another hangout way
I'm had Michael Hurwitz with me and he's
an author on my website and we are
talking today about starting a business
and running a business with your spouse
or with your family
um Michael has his own companies had it
for awhile and we're trying to figure
out what what topic might be good to
discuss today and so that was the one
that came up with so Michael for those
of the viewers who you know aren't
familiar with you can you give a quick
intro absolutely careers in government
which is like monster or career builder
but specifically for local government
was actually one of the very first in
the space it was started in 1996
actually by my in-laws and my
father-in-law who's still a city manager
today but has been a city manager for
years and years and years and about in
the mid 90s at that time when you had a
job posting you would you know basically
fax off your job posting requirements
and then it was put into a job pamphlet
and then mailed out to local government
officials and my father-in-law saw as
well as my mother-in-law saw that you
know there was an opportunity to
obviously create a job board monster was
just starting at the time and actually
my wife great story my wife started
helping out my in-laws and use that
experience to become one of the founders
of hot jobs so she has tremendous
experience in you know that space of the
job board industry so fast forward when
I started dating my wife you know her
parents were still running it was very
successful business but you know they
were at the retirement age I think they
were looking to you know close shop and
right from the get-go our relationship
was all about the business in a good way
very positive way and so you know we
started talking about hey maybe we
should take over the business this is
when we were still dating we were I
think we just I might have proposed but
it was around that time so the business
is really part of our
our whole family nucleus which is very
cool so her in-laws have helped us to
this day grow the business I've got my
wife working with us her sister helps us
as well as our staff and everyone else
that obviously helped but it's such a
unique situation and very rare where you
have a family situation really helping
out and you know when you think about it
that's how American businesses started
in the United States it was all about
family businesses family farms
everything else I think people kind of
forgotten that that's a great way to
start a business and grow as a couple is
having business yeah how long ago is
that when you guys first started this or
when you guys first started dating yeah
we took it over we we've been married
about three years we took it over about
four years the site had never been
updated I mean literally it was like
circa 1996 with the AOL CD ROMs remember
you had to load them in and get your AOL
internet that's a site like an AOL
homepage I mean it was horribly outdated
no social media presence no marketing
effort we took over the business from
ground zero and now we have major
partnerships with some of the largest
government associations in the country
we're by far the leader in local
government job boards and more
importantly we're very active on social
media with our blog one of the largest
blogs in local government and thanks to
you Evan and your organization you've
helped get our message out which is
fantastic and we now have more than a
hundred writers that contribute to us
from government employers and jobseekers
to really you know government thought
leaders who are really kind of creating
the next trend of employment in
government and we're trying to bring
that message to as many people as
possible that hey you know what local
government is a great place to work got
hit by the recession and now they're
looking to hire and you're seeing a lot
of Millennials looking at you know hey I
want to change the world I want to do
everything like that I want to be part
of the community well this is a great
way to be a part of the community it's
not about the money always in government
as we know it's about making a
difference and at local government you
really can make a difference cool so
let's talk about working with your
working with your spouse you know I
thought you've been a fan of working
with with friends and family I've had
great results with it but some people
we'll say that's crazy I could never
walk my wife I could never work in my
in-laws what am i if somebody who's
thinking about that or who's in that and
is having some issues
I you know I made a list of things it
was funny because I was thinking this
morning like you know what drove my wife
Cory and I to work together and what
made it successful and in a lot of ways
our business relationship is equally as
successful as our marriage and and what
drives that common goals you know when
you're sitting there and you have a
business partner that let's say you just
met a few months ago where he has a
financial investment your company you
don't know him beyond the parameters of
that initial meeting or that initial
friendship marriage is very different
you've got to rely on your partner if
she doesn't pull her weight or if you
don't pull your weight you're gonna hear
about it that night you're gonna hear
about that day and you're gonna see it
in your bank account so you know it is
all about common goals and you know we
really sat down and said okay you know
what do we want out of this business
what do we want to accomplish what are
our short term midterm and long term
goals and we constantly reevaluate that
so I think that's one aspect is what's
the common goal you know a lot of people
say I want to grow a big business it's
not enough you know you got to get down
to the minutia and that's where
personally for me and I think you hear
this a lot it's all about delegating
work there is no way that two people can
work together on every project so my
wife handles certain tasks I handle
certain tasks you're given the you know
approval where the person is given the
authority kind of run with their program
or run with their department if they
want advice from the spouse they ask for
it but at the same time the spouse
realizes look they're in charge of it
and you have to take a step back and you
have to trust your partner like in
business but it's a little harder when
you have an emotional connection you
know say hey well wait a minute how
about we do it this way with your spouse
you have to talk about it but then you
have to say you know what she knows best
that's her area and move forward so
that's another areas you know delegate
and then give kind of that authorship to
that task you know separate office
partners in this or somebody we're not
we took over the business officially
from her parents and then you know we
kept on some staff hired new staff and
changed around but yeah we took over a
hundred percent ownership and that's
actually a very interesting point
because if someone does start a business
and they bring in a spouse you gotta
have 50/50 partnership I know some
people saying well you know I'm the guy
or the female saying hey you know I
started the business I want the
ownership in a marriage it's 50/50
whether you like it or not no matter
what someone did more so beforehand or
not I mean my wife the reality is it was
her in-laws that helped us start it she
had the background but if she'd gone in
and said hey I want 70% I would have
been like no sorry so you know you gotta
realize that hey this is a fair
partnership in life and in work you have
to you know you have to have it fair
so in decision-making you know on the
big picture stuff I get to the task you
know you have your thing she has hers
but what if you disagree on a big
picture issue or like it's something
that the president would make a decision
on how do you handle you know it's
interesting that's a great topic so you
know some of that is based on the
delegation so with the delegation let's
say there is a project that has
significant impact on the business but
it's under you know my authority so to
speak or her authority you have to
really let that person say look okay
it's under your department you know I'll
take a step back now if it has
significant impact we'll sit down we'll
work it through it will decide hey you
know what this is really important
enough to where we have to work together
and make a decision but usually on most
issues you know my wife has authority on
her areas I have authority on mine and
to be honest I always tell my wife I
don't want to worry about her business
you know it's I've got enough to worry
about I want I know and trust her
implicitly I want her to run with it if
it's a major project she shares it with
me and vice versa and then you know it's
again it's that kind of balance like in
marriage sometimes you're gonna have to
you know give up the fight for the big
picture and sometimes you got to stand
strong but you know in marriage is a guy
knows you
some way when your wife says this is how
that's all so how'd you guys split up
your rolls what is your department and
what is hers in your business well you
know it's interesting and and that's
another thing it's evolved over time
right so in the beginning she oversaw
all the sales because I came from
advertising I used to work in the print
world USA Today Gannett and overseen
their advertising and marketing so I
stayed on with my job as my wife who you
know was running a full-time with our
staff was kind of taking the you know
the bull by the horns and running with
it and dealing with it I was kind of
sitting on the sidelines you know
assisting where I could and so my wife
got very comfortable with working with a
lot of the employers so for the single
job postings and job posting packages
she would handle all that right and as I
started moving in and started developing
partnerships with large government
associations like for example we work
with the National Association of
counties which is the largest National
Association of counties in the country
were overseeing all their job board
career efforts and also with IPM a it's
the world's largest Association of
Personnel Management for government
we're overseeing their entire job board
resource Anor career resources blog etc
so I was bringing in those partnerships
and she decided you know you continue
with those partnerships develop that
angle let me run with this area so a lot
of it is organic in terms of who handles
what my wife does the billing on the
company and you know is kind of the CFO
along with our bookkeepers but I then
decided hey you know what she's busy
with that I'll handle the the financials
for the house itself you know and then
she can handle it so things kind of work
out organically and then you build on
that and obviously as a person gets more
and more experience in their space the
other person realizes hey they get it
and I'm so busy here with anything with
bandwidth it's all about bandwidth in a
rural environment you kind of step back
and say you know what keep growing it
and it kind of organically developed so
now she does all the finances she runs
all the the job posting programs a lot
of the sales and I'm doing business
development with the government
association so you know it really kind
of came up
naturally and it's grown from there and
it's been quite successful looks awesome
nah yeah um a lot of entreprenuer their
wives they have a hard time when they
come home because then you're still just
talking business and it's business 24/7
and some people love that but have you
created rituals or you know schedules
are so you don't bring it home all the
time
oh that's a great point you know and I
made a note I said don't bring work into
the bedroom literally and that's part of
the problem is you know we'll have our
laptops in bed talking about business
it's like that's not where business
should you know be taking place
obviously there's other rooms to have
business so it's very hard
my wife is type a I'm type a and you
know if we're in the car running an air
and if we're you know at our date night
we're talking about business and some of
that is enjoyable some of that obviously
it's a shared experience but you know
it's hard to separate because that's
what you do all day long and I kind of
got to the point where I decided you
know what when I had my other job and
when Corey was doing another job she
would talk about her work and I would
still talk about my work so I figured
you know what it's kind of natural to
still talk about your work but it is a
it's a balance and we haven't set up the
okay tonight's date night let's not talk
about this because there again is that
kind of organic like hey we're real busy
with business let's talk about business
tonight we have some time to catch up on
things but it does it can impact the
marriage you know again for us it's been
an all positive for other people
business is difficult you're talking
about negative things so you know one
ritual I do have and it's personal
ritual but my wife has taken it on is on
Fridays we always have kind of the
gratitude checklist where we go through
and say these the things we've
accomplished this is where we were you
know this is where we were at in January
this was her Bowl by July we've
accomplished it lets you know revel in
that opportunities they hate we're doing
things we're doing things correctly and
that is to me I think that's the
greatest thing you know just taking a
step back and saying these are the
things we've accomplished together Cory
for our business appreciative of that
and then it allows you to kind of you
know gets you that next
that next wave of energy to accomplish
what you need to accomplish but always
focusing on what we've done right not
just saying oh you've done this wrong or
I can't do this right what are we doing
together correctly and then you know
build on that and it builds trust doing
that the gratitude Fridays is that how
you start the day and today when you're
doing I usually fortunately we live
close to Malibu right in California so
Malibu is about 20-minute Drive so we
take a Beach Walk Friday afternoon maybe
late in the day Friday and that's kind
of our thing
a lot of times if she's busy I'll still
do the walk and you just you know 10-15
minutes thinking about these are the
things I wanted to accomplish when you
know when I started out this January or
you know when Corey and I started the
business together when we were dating
who would have guessed we would have
accomplished XY and Z and you know when
you take a step back and appreciate that
you you do realize the magnitude of what
you have accomplished and that allows
you to then go on to accomplish that
much more because you know if you got
from there to here you can get even
further
it's a great I mean whether you're in
the business with your spouse or not
it's a great ritual exactly exactly so
you bought I guess you got it from your
in-laws that they still involved are you
still working with your in-laws great
question so you know we don't have an
official executive board but luckily her
dad has he's been in city government for
pretty much his whole life right and my
wife was actually after she helped sell
hot job to Yahoo she continued on as a
teacher in the school district in Los
Angeles and has more than eight years as
a schoolteacher so there's a strong
public sector background with my in-laws
and especially her dad is extremely
strategic in his analysis of what works
in government he's very entrepreneurial
you don't get that a lot of times in
government but my father was extremely
entrepreneurial very forward-thinking
and what government can accomplish
developing public private partnerships
etc so he's always involved in
high-level strategic meetings a lot of
times if we have major meetings with
government associations we want to do
some content partnership
or job board partnerships he can bring
in some advice and the great thing about
working with my father-in-law a he
doesn't have any financial involvement
so you know he doesn't have that tied in
secondly he's retired so he wants to
still be involved he still you know look
he's 62 in government that's like
starting out because average age in
government is probably about 70 so he
wants to be involved so he enjoys you
know getting involved with us
strategically but then he can step back
saying hey you know what this isn't
gonna affect my bank account I'm just
helping out my son-in-law and my dog and
my daughter so this is something that
you know I'd love to do and he's been a
tremendous resource and of course my
mother-in-law herself started the
business and really ran it from day to
day so she was instrumental when we
first launched a business and helping us
say okay you know this is where we were
at four years ago how do you kind of
rebrand yourself and market yourself to
the same people that she was dealing
with and then take it beyond so they've
really each played a significant role in
the success of our business and you know
from where we were three years ago to
just where we are now it's beyond our
wildest expectations has been great it
really has I mean we're by far the
leader in this space and you know we
didn't expect it so quickly that's
awesome yeah you know you're such a
great story and it's worked out well and
everybody's you know getting along and
you're getting results I'm trying to
figure out well how can we make this
more replicable so other entrepreneurs
we're thinking about working for spouse
can can do the same thing and I think of
a buddy of mine he's got he's got a
business it's you know just crossed a
million in sales he's thinking of
bringing on his wife and in the domingos
she'd be great out of his had a hard
time filling that role but he's worried
about you know that was a single income
house and and he worked with his wife
and you know if it doesn't work out what
you do so is there you know if you're
thinking about it how do you is there
way to test it you know how do you I
don't know how to get over that fear of
if it doesn't work out then you know
she's quit her job and now you know it's
not working out what do we do is that
how do you how do you test it or how do
you reduce the risk at the start getting
into it
and then that's like the million dollar
question isn't it um you know it's funny
there is no way to plan but I should say
there is a way to plan but there's no
way to know so you know in terms of
planning my wife and I decided you know
when we first were growing the business
she would be the one to jump in with
both feet right I was continuing my work
and you know I would help when I could
at nights or on weekend she ran a full
time and then we waited to see okay how
was the business growing where's our
revenue at can we live on this how much
do we need to reinvest then once we got
to the point where it's like okay
Michael now you can jump into it with
both feet even then how much money do we
have in the bank account you know
because like you said the big question
is you're now a single income family you
depend on that business that business is
your child and it's either gonna keep
the both of you very happy or you got to
go back into the private sector which
would be miserable right I don't want to
work for you know anyone else after
running the business so it was a lot of
planning going into it
and you know we're very careful with
money this and that but a lot of it is
you know just taking that risk at a
certain point it's like you know what
jump into it I knew my wife the one
thing that I knew implicitly was she was
such a hustler so hard-working so
skillful of what she does
knowledgeable of what she does dedicated
to making a success I knew that I
couldn't get a better partner I've never
had a better partner both as a wife as
well as a business partner and from
there I felt comfortable saying you know
what I'm gonna quit my job in corporate
America even though you know it was
still growing we you know we're ready to
live on the money the whole thing we
were reinvesting that you know at a
certain point I got the right partner I
got the right pieces in place now I just
I gotta jump into it it may not work but
I got to jump into it and that's kind of
where I was at was okay you know what
we're gonna jump into this but not
knowing 100% where it's gonna go and you
still don't know you know it's you know
how it is that's the beauty of being an
entrepreneur but I'll tell you one of
the two of my greatest decisions in life
one was meeting my wife and marrying her
and the other was going into business
together and it sounds corny but it's
the greatest thing
having your own time your own freedom
creating your own thing and doing it
with the one you love and making it
happen
you know good and bad you go through it
that's what being a couple is all about
right it's about creating a joint goal
and making it happen and how better can
you express that than in a business and
that's kind of that to me summarizes
what a marriage is all about is you know
starting a business is a great
expression of that marriage and so you
work so you were doing a hard time at
the start while still having your your
job you left and put both feet in and so
I guess through that part-time
experience you can see hey are we
working together well are we fighting
over this isn't causing you know
detriment to our marriage or is it or is
it helping it grow stronger and for you
to you know it was strengthened you guys
about you guys even closer together
so maybe there's having some kind of
check point or oh yeah while you try
part-time evenings or whatever it is and
see you know you have your Friday
gratitude session and see is this thing
for us or not you know I think you hit
it right on the head which is you know
especially to your friend who's thinking
about that is almost kind of a pilot
program in the sense that you know I
wasn't completely ready to quit you know
the one thing Cory and I do is we jump
into things and we test things out you
have to you have to take risks as an
entrepreneur but they have to be
calculated as much as possible so if
you're gonna jump into you know a
marriage situation and then work do a
test pilot program hey you know have
your wife or husband get involved on a
specific project see how well you work
together see where the conflict points
are and work through nothing's gonna be
perfect obviously that's just that's the
reality but at least you can know
sometimes it wow this is a problem he's
not pulling his weight she's not doing
this and either work through him or not
because we knew pretty early on okay we
get along really well in terms of work
where we have the same mentality and you
can't hold grudges
you know if it's someone you know I work
at Starbucks all the time right I go out
and and I work in different environments
depending upon what kind of meetings I
have for the day or I'm on the road with
meetings or Cory's on the road with
meeting but
you know she can work from bed she can
work downstairs she can work it you know
wherever she needs to work but you can't
hold any kind of like well it works for
me it should work for you you have to
accept that they're doing it because it
works for them and then you let them run
with it and that to me is the most
important thing it's just that trust
factor once you trust it's like be on
your way do it I know it's going to
happen and then come to me if you have
if you want advice or needed otherwise
run with it I like the pilot program you
date before you get married right so
yeah that's cool um so you have it you
have a team to write your people who
were not for you do they have any issues
they you know know who to talk to about
different issues or is it you know
whatever department it is you know some
people talk to you some people talk to
her great question you know that's
another thing too where you know when
you're in the workplace and you have a
manager sometimes you want to you know
show off to your manager you want to you
know highlight why you would be the best
candidate if perhaps the VP's involved
you know there's always some kind of
political angling but if you're the
business owner and you have people
reporting if it's an issue that let's
say my wife has overseen and I've maybe
on the conference call I have to
acquiesce my wife makes the decision let
her rule up because you don't want to
get into a bickering situation you see
it on TV shows all the time where
couples work together and the employees
cannot stand it so very clear even on
before a meeting before we go in any
meeting Corinne I'll be like okay you
know do you want to run with this
meeting it's your show or this is your
project I'll listen in and you can give
advice or whatever but ultimately you
know it shows respect to your business
partner and wife and vice versa
and it also shows respect to your staff
because you don't need to have your
staff know what's going on like oh my
god they had a fight last night and
they're bringing it in the workplace
right Bob you really have to be
professional and a lot of what we do you
know we have interns come in here we
have a lot of people who are contract we
do a lot of you know skyping things like
that
we're always on calls and you know
there's times where I know Cory wants to
beat me in the head and I want to beat
her in the head and you just have to
step back and say you know we're on a
business meeting this is professional
like in any situation and after the
professional manner
so is your staff aligned with that you
know you have your staff she has her
staff or your staff will overlap and you
make decisions for some of them and
right how did you structure your team
yeah it's great I mean you know we have
we have a social media team and I
predominantly oversee that but Cory
chimes in because Cory is very strong
and LinkedIn very very strong and
LinkedIn and actually helps set up our
Twitter account to grow I took it over
about a year ago to grow it even further
and get more involved in other social
media efforts with government
associations it's the same team that we
deal with but now they you know they'll
come to me but I you know Cory and I are
very careful about never playing any
games with staff it's immediately like
you know what I think Cory handles that
talked to Cory if she acquiesces and
gives it back to me then call me but
there's never any kind of underhanded
yes where you would get that in the
private sector obviously in corporate
America you do that on purpose here you
have to really work so that you can have
you know the staff respects my wife the
staff respects us and you got to do that
by saying look you know what no you
can't turn around and say oh yeah Cory
she's not in charge of that you know
just come to me the minute you start
doing this adapt will sniff it out and
they'll use it to their advantage
obviously and it'll hurt you in the log
right how do you guys have do you have
titles of both co-founders or when he
took this young paddle she took when she
took the CEO title well because she had
started it I mean in the sense that you
know she was taking this full-time while
I was still part-time I took the
president title
we're both co-founders but when we talk
you know we just it's not like oh she's
the CEO or the president you know and
when we you know it's interesting in
government too and this is actually
tarred Vanek government is a very
close-knit industry it really is it's
all about much like the entertainment
business it's all about who you know and
people love the fact that we were a
family-run business when it was
it was started out by my father-in-law
who was in government it was taken over
by my wife who is in the public sector
um you know we're all kind of this
family unit and government loves that so
we use it to our advantage because you
know we really believe in the public
sector believe what local government can
do and you know it's one thing for a
private sector company that just is
trying to break into local government
saying oh I understand your process I
can help local government out versus
someone who says that's our DNA we are
about local government we understand
local government and this is how we can
help you and that's been heavily
influential in helping us secure some
pretty large programs with government
association and I think helping us to
continue to grow very cool Michael we
are bumping up against the clock it's
been awesome having you on board I think
you should write up on this it's gonna
help a lot of entrepreneurs are trying
to figure this out for those people
watching people want to learn more about
you where can they go to learn more
obviously the articles of my site but
where else can they find me website
social they can go to careers in
government comm they can email me at
Michael at careers in government comm
and we're on Twitter at careers in gov
and real thank 11 because we love being
a partner with you we love what you do
and it's great talking to you this
half-hour yeah it's been awesome meeting
you thanks so much for joining in
absolutely take care all right Cheers
okay